[Musique]
ghislaine sabine bonjour bonjour mr
trenca ruche alors vous faites partie
donc on l'a dit du collectif 0
chlordécone 0 poison et vous vous êtes
associé vous avez fait un liant nage
quand vous dites avec l'association le
roseau pour organiser en cette fin de
semaine samedi
précisément la journée de samedi nous y
reviendrons
un village santé alors d'abord vous êtes
à l'origine avec le collectif 0
chlordécone 0 poison de l'interpellation
d'un certain nombre de responsables
concernant les tests de dépistage du
taux de chlordécone dans le sang alors
tout ça c'est parti on le rappelle quand
même dit lis un peu plus d'un an de deux
étudiants deux étudiants en deuxième
année de bts agricole qui avaient eux
mêmes lancé une pétition au début de
l'année 2018
intitulé je suis chlore déconner et puis
ça a été donc relayé ensuite par vous
même
alors cette pétition a été adressée tant
à la ministre de la santé qu'au préfet
de guadeloupe et de martinique un
certain nombre de parlementaires s'en
sont saisis ici par exemple ça a été
relayé également par la fédération
socialiste de la martinique est plus
d'un an après tout cela ghislaine sabine
où en est on est ce que vous avez eu des
nouvelles de la part des pouvoirs
publics
ici ou là bas je vais reprendre c'est un
petit peu parce qu'avec ces deux jeunes
effectivement étudiants dont ses
contacts et on était déjà aussi un
collectif qui portait un enseignement le
nom le collectif contre l'épandage
aérien et non pas seulement des
martiniquais donc depuis 2012 nous avons
eu des actions
d'aucuns de en 2018 nous avons changé de
nom pour porter collectif contre le
collectif 0 chlordécone 0 poison donc
nous nous sommes rencontrés et là il va
on a fait des petites réunions bon il
était surtout effectivement comme il
était là en tant qu'étudiant ils n'ont
pas voulu aller autres guillemets plus
loin effectivement cette pétition qu'ils
avaient voilà ça a été relayée par vous
alors ça a été payant tout le duigou
on est alors nous mêmes nous avons mis
en place une pétition en 2018
oui par rapport à ça surtout pas pour
les tests gratuits
rafa n'a plus rien à voile à la gratuité
à roulettes s oui c'est ça alors oui
parce que à l'époque je sais pas si il
me semble que ça a changé sa baisser un
petit peu il en coûtait 140 euros non
remboursés pour faire un test
maintenant je crois que nous avons avec
des petits de cause justement non
vraiment avec avec les deux laboratoires
bio label bio santé donc nous avons nous
n'avons voilà un accord pour qu'il
puisse faire baisser et donc c'est entre
70 et 80 euros
donc nous ne sommes pas au niveau aussi
aux meilleurs nage entre guillemets avec
le collectif
comment s'appelle le haut voilà l'eau et
donc et nous avons monté le projet en
fait clair détox d'accord donc ça c'est
un projet c'est vraiment cette de
melleray pas voilà très bien mais la
pétition donc est ce que vous avez pu
obtenir quelque chose parce que bon avec
vos démarches vous avec deux
laboratoires vous avez pu effectivement
obtenir que les prix baissent un peu le
coup mais notamment jeudi les pouvoirs
publics l'état puisque ça à lui que vous
adressez principalement
qu'est ce que est ce que c'est les
choses ont progressé
rappelez-nous aussi le nombre de
signatures que votre pétition a
recueilli parce que là c'est fini c'est
terminé on pas la pétition de 2018 2
juillet 2018
elle est à vingt mille signataires ouais
donc il s'est adressé à continuer
et ça continue aujourd'hui oui oui oui
oui parce que ça c'est un truc de longue
haleine un bon il faut savoir que quand
on voit effectivement le résultat ce que
dit le président donc on nous on a
adressé cette pétition aux deux préfets
c'est à dire martinique et guadeloupe a
donc
et de toute façon à l'état donc pour les
deux îles qui sont empoisonnés par le
chlordécone a avancé pour l'instant non
non on n'a rien eu on n'a pas eu beau on
a vu quand même le préfet au mois de
2 novembre bomboli et c'est
effectivement d'orly est beau mais bon
c'est le gouvernement donc on attend de
toute façon on ne baisse pas les bras
face à cette pétition
on continue effectivement de partager et
surtout bon comme on a commencé notre
plan de notre plan chlordécone donc
toute façon sellier pour l'instant les
gens effectivement paye c'est oui parce
que ce que l'objet principal de cette
pétition
c'est une demande de prise en charge
financière par l'état par l'état
français brille parce que cesse du test
pour notamment pour les personnes qui
ont été exposées alors les martys voilà
c'est les guadeloupéens
oui demandes ont effectivement une
gratuité car de toute façon nous pensons
et nous savons que nous sommes pas
responsables de cela alors donc là on a
fait le point sur cette pétition vous
dites que ça continue donc ceux qui
voudraient donc y adhérer la signer
pourquoi falloir le faire oui on peut
nous trouver sur notre page facebook
zéro chlordécone 0 poison et de façon si
on tape effectivement pétition 0
chlordécone on va on va retrouver cette
pétition sur le net
très bien donc avec l'association le
roseau vous donc collectif 0 chlordécone
0 poison que vous représentez ici ce
matin guy lannes sabine vous avez décidé
d'organiser un village santé samedi
prochain samedi 30 mars de 8h à 16h sur
le parcours santé à à ducos
vous l'avez donc intitulé baptisé ce
village santé en belle santé sans
poissons alors allez on ne revient c'est
vraiment ça c'est au vêlage en belle
santé sans parents on y revient de toute
façon et sur ce projet en fait il a
débuté au mois de choual année dernière
avec l'association le roseau qui nous a
contactés et donc donc on a cru un mot
de mots sur cette association rapidement
juste
enfin c'est une association fête qui se
trouve sur la commune de ducos c'est une
association en fait qui fait pas mal de
choses culturelles au sein de la ville
de ducos des sorties éducatives des
choses pour les personnes âgées enfin
voilà alors qu'est ce que vous allez
proposer qu'est-ce qu'on pourra voir sur
donc dans à ce village santé en belle
santé sans poison alors voilà le début
de ce village avait commencé par une
marche dans la ville de ducos donc c'est
pour on peut rappeler au jour de cette
manifestation et on retournera donc sûr
parce que ça se passe au parcours de
santé de ducos donc on retournera
parcours de santé
et là on va commencer avec du fitness
baylet et ensuite nous allons nous
présenter pourquoi nous avons
effectivement voulu cette manifestation
et il nous aurons aussi une conférence
débat avec le dr jose plage et il y aura
aussi le docteur mcnee qui interviendra
pour denis aussi des parce que voilà il
a hélas d'expérience avec ces malades
donc il a des choses au fait aussi à
dire donc tout au long de la journée
nous aurons aussi des artistes nous
avons surtout notre marraine nicole
catch qui portera avec bon c'est qu'elle
est lé poète écrivaine elle est
chanteuse
donc elle portera toute cette journée à
bras le corps effectivement et puis fera
entendre fille aussi ses doléances à ce
niveau là nous avons des artistes tels
que vaïty et heart anna non on a aussi
déjà là qui viendra qui viendra de lors
de la manifestation et luc andres est
aussi un poète kif qui de la ville de
ducos donc et puis de nombreux autres
alors on aura des stands
ah oui voilà pourquoi je veux dire vu
que vous l'avez appelé village donc donc
leurs distances au jour dans cet esprit
en bonne santé sans poison toujours donc
on a on aura le marché qui est zéro
chlordécone c'est comme ça qui va
s'appeler 0 corps de l'école dont toutes
les personnes effectivement qui
viendront on le sait parce qu'on a une
liste d' art de 2,00 chlordécone avec le
label c'est ça qui viennent on n'en
pense pas seulement avec le label note
c'est à dire que ce sont des gens qui
ont fait tester leurs terres ah oui
c'est ce que j'allais dire parce que
voilà ce que vous avez des éléments
probants tout ce qui montre
c'est des personnages qui entravent nous
avons fait de la permaculture avec eux à
plusieurs reprises
donc c'est des personnes qui viendront
effectivement sur sur cette
manifestation en ayant effectivement
leurs fruits et légumes de toute façon 0
chlordécone même pas une terre même pas
de là il ne faut pas pousser
même hors sol si vraiment c'est une
couleur déconne donc on n'aura pas
seulement on aura des toutes sortes de
deux stands
effectivement on aura le centre de
bien-être aussi on aura le oui j'aime
jouer parce qu'il faut il faut conclure
plaisir juste oui non même conclure ce
que je voulais vous de jugez vous
demandez vous préciser c'est
qu'évidemment c'est une manifestation
gratuite enfin la porter en pays où la
porte est ouverte
elle est gratuite effectivement nous
l'avons pas précédents précisé sur notre
flyers mais c'est une manifestation
gratuite aller ouverte à tout le monde
et nous invitons les gens effectivement
tout toute la martinique entre
guillemets un possible avenir métro 7
heures du matin et 16 heures très bien
merci ghislaine sabine donc vous les
invités à venir samedi donc prochains
samedis 30 mars sur le parcours santé 2
du cos pour donc ce village santé un
belle santé c'est un poison
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions ce
matin bonne journée merci beaucoup de
nous avoir invités papa
[Musique]